when does social media government
collaboration cross the line from
voluntary information sharing into
illegal censorship that's the question
at the center of Missouri V Biden a case
that's made its way to the fifth Circuit
Court of Appeals and it was the subject
of a recent live stream with Attorney
John vecchione and Jay bhattacharya
professor of medicine economics and
health research policy at Stanford
University who's a plaintiff in the case
my primary goal in this case is to
restore free speech so that science can
actually function again badacharya was a
co-author of the Great Barrington
declaration in October 2020 open letter
calling for an end to covid-19 lockdowns
and advocating instead for a strategy
called focused protection of the elderly
and vulnerable documents obtained
through a Freedom of Information Act
request revealed NIH director Francis
Collins emailed Anthony fauci calling
for a quick and devastating takedown of
the letter fauci blasted The Proposal as
nonsense in multiple media interviews
though denied in a taped deposition that
he'd coordinated statements with Collins
or that he had anything to do with the
social media suppression of bhattacharya
and his colleagues that was later
revealed via the Twitter files so your
statement was made within two days of Dr
Collins's statement to The Washington
Post correct right uh did you guys
coordinate on making those statements
did you discuss it with each other that
you're going to make these statements
criticizing the Great Barrington
declaration other than the emails you've
already seen I don't believe so but I'm
not one no I don't that's not a style to
be coordinating things but I don't know
it's possible we discussed it depends on
what your definition of coordination is
and the same time frame did you become
aware that the Great Barrington
Declaration was being censored in social
media
I'm not aware of any censorship of of
anything Dr fauci uh rather than try to
Grapple with the actual critique we had
uh essentially organized a propaganda
campaign countering the Great Barrington
declaration with coordinated statements
to the media that straw man the details
of the proposal might be unethical but
it is legal the question at the center
of this case is whether the resulting
suppression of covid policy dissenters
like batacharya was voluntary private
action or illegal government coercion
take this March 2021 Roundtable
organized by Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis YouTube removed it because of
the views bharacharya and others
expressed about masking children in
school how do you teach a child to read
with face masks on on Zoom I mean I
think it's development developmentally
inappropriate and it just doesn't help
on the on the Z spread I think it's
absolutely not the right thing to do
when YouTube suppressed that video of a
sitting Governor uh talking to a
scientific advisors in public so he so
that the public can understand the
scientific advasis for which he's making
decisions
I was stunned I mean I thought I I like
I thought like good government group
should be fair or that even if you
disagree with what I said at least you
want to know what the advice the
governor is getting right when Elon Musk
released the Twitter files to
journalists we learned that bhattacharya
had been blacklisted which means the
reach of his post was suppressed we also
learned that Twitter Executives were in
constant communication with federal law
enforcement about problematic posts and
users Discovery in this court case
revealed a similar back Channel between
the CDC Facebook and YouTube as reported
on by reasons Robbie Suave I think
everyone who got into this thought well
it's Silicon Valley they probably want
to keep certain views out because
they're all a mono a mono culture with
all the same views right and all that we
didn't find that I mean all the lawyers
on this case I think have been kind of
stunned that Facebook was pushing back
um you they were all poking pushing back
and the government's yelling at them
about it so it was not the case and I
think that makes the our case stronger
that these companies were all like yeah
we want to do this we'd be doing this
without this pressure without these
calls and these threats the plaintiffs
argue that the government's strong-armed
big Tech into doing its bidding with the
constant threat to impose Anti-Trust
regulation and revoke section 230
protections which Shield website owners
from liability for user-generated posts
both Biden and his press secretary
jensaki repeatedly invoked this threat
in public I've never been a big
Zuckerberg fan I think think he's a real
problem
section 230 should be revoked the
president's view is that the major
platforms have a responsibility related
to the health and safety of all
Americans to stop amplifying
untrustworthy content disinformation and
misinformation he also supports better
privacy protections and a robust
Anti-Trust program accuses social media
companies of killing people for allowing
vaccine myths to circulate online
they're killing people the president has
long been concerned about the power of
large social media platforms what they
have that power they have over our
everyday lives has long argued that Tech
platforms must be held accountable for
the harms they cause he's been a strong
supporter of fundamental reforms to
achieve that goal including reforms to
section 230 enacting Anti-Trust reforms
does it abridge speech I think it does I
think that you're bringing to bear this
is worth billions 230 is worth billions
to these companies but an oral argument
since the government's attorney said
that the social media companies
voluntarily sought help from the
government during the pandemic and 2020
election and that the prosecution has no
proof of a direct threat if you were
saying we're going to do this you know
if you don't do this we're going to
impose some penalty some government
regulation or sanction on you that's not
the way you would go about it you
wouldn't say I'm really mad you would
just say do this or else and or else
would be clear your free speech rights
are violated when the government stops
your message from getting out it's clear
it happened to Jay bhattacharya and
anybody associated with the Great
Barrington because they may not have
used his name but they said we want to
take down the Great Barrington
declaration and everything associated
with it that wasn't done by these
companies so their first amendment
rights were taken away by the government
because absent the government you take
away the hand of the government and it
wouldn't have happened that's what all
the facts show in July a district court
judge ordered the federal government to
seize all communication with social
media companies having to do with
takedowns until the case was heard but
that injunction was reversed after the
government appealed to the U.S fifth
Circuit Court bhattacharya says that
regardless of what happens in this case
an organized political movement is what
is needed to restore free speech and
open scientific inquiry in America I've
always had this feeling that this idea
that it would be science that would that
would be that would that would win the
day rather than brought political power
I unfortunately don't see any other way
other than to have this as a political
fight uh in in the in the political
arena in order to win and I don't know
which direction it's going to go
Missouri V Biden may help determine the
future of free speech in America and by
focusing their sights on government
actors rather than the private companies
under their boot the plaintiffs have
chosen exactly the right targets the the
recourse to this kind of coercive power
this suppression and violation of First
Amendment rights happened because the
government failed to Garner the trust of
the American public
they're acting in this way because they
don't know how else to regain the trust
hey that video was based on a longer
conversation that I had with Jay
bhattacharya and John vecchioni about
the Missouri V Biden case you can see
that full conversation right here or a
clip from that conversation right over
here thank you
[Music]